[Music]
aha
it's gonna work i think we got it cool
all right awesome so thanks everybody uh
for for joining
today we're going to talk about hey
robin we're going to talk about
data science in meat space and
i have a couple of objectives with this
talk
i want to share for anyone that's
interested in
in doing data science in meat space uh
that it's incredibly rewarding
uh if it's your niche uh you know niches
are filters uh but that's that's a good
thing if it's if it's what you're into
it's gonna be a heck of a lot of fun um
and for those who are already doing work
in this space i want to share some of my
experiences maybe it'll be helpful
for you maybe we can talk more outside
of this
and i think honestly a lot of this stuff
is pretty universal similar workflows
and paradigms apply whether you're
whether you're doing data science in
meat space or elsewhere so maybe it'll
still be interesting
if you're just hanging out for the next
talk
i don't know what the bird thing is
about but people put them on their slide
so i did that
um cool so uh what is meat space
uh it's the opposite of cyber space
right so it's the physical world
um and it's a really weird term there's
like
some confusion on the internet about
where it came from it's like this word
that's
the opposite of a concept
that it predates um i don't know
but that's not what it talks about just
yeah it's physical world so
i know what you're thinking how am i
going to run my spark job
on the abacus um but that's not quite
the the deal so i'm going to talk a
little bit
for a couple slides just about what my
background is to give you sort of
a bit of flavor of the type of work that
i'm doing
when i talk about mute space
so i worked at tesla for a bunch of
years i worked on all of these
the vehicle programs we did some other
programs with toyota and daimler
we also made some some batteries lots of
lots of things
and what i was working on there
specifically was around manufacturing
uh for for the battery so sean lop
specifically asked for a slide with
gratuitous robots on it so this
is a tesla manufacturing facility
this isn't this isn't battery that's
that parts it's too secret
but this is this is uh some robots that
are building the car
doing doing body assembly um and so like
what is what is the type of work that
you're doing as a data scientist in a
manufacturing place
uh like like tesla so some of the work
involves like
setting test limits uh for quality
control
right looking at empirical data figuring
out what the right
places are to draw some some test lines
um doing optimization so there's process
parameters
knobs dials levers you know there's not
actually any
lovers but you have to optimize this
process
uh and put the right parameters in the
process to make it work really
efficiently to
reduce costs excuse me reduce costs or
improve yields
a lot of the things we worked on were
vision systems
sometimes it was for measurement
there's some cool cases where we would
take apart we would image it
we'd find locations of specific uh
components
and then you could feed that back to a
robot that was doing the process and it
would
basically do like a bespoke or tailored
process
that was aware of the specific
orientation configuration dimensions
things like that of the
the part that it was working on we also
did a lot of
vision systems to do defect detection
now what i do is uh like you know what's
more fun than robots
assembling inanimate objects well it's
robots
that assemble plants
and uh it's it's interesting it's very
similar in a lot of ways
i still kind of think of it as a
manufacturing role
but instead of assembling an animated
objects it's a sort of life support
in combination with all the same
automation equipment
and robots so i work at this company
called plenty
we're based in in south san francisco
and what we do is we
grow grow plants in indoors and we do
kind of the same types of work so
there's a lot of work
uh defining test limits um but it's
unique here because we're we're doing
phenotyping as well right
so you and your sibling are both
human beings and that's good but you
look different right and you have
different
different morphologies um and so we need
to capture those things in this context
and we still have limits and controls
around that
we still have the same concept of uh
optimizing our process parameters but
it's
um but it's really about modeling plant
growth and figuring out in this
controlled environment agriculture
how can we give it the the right inputs
to maximize growth and flavor and things
like that
we also have a lot of vision systems for
the same same types of things
and there's some some unique stuff too
um like i said about modeling plant
growth
it's kind of like a longitudinal set of
data that we have we have a cohort of
plants that we're growing and we track
them over time
so a lot of that stuff i think is
similar to what some other folks here do
um looking at pathogens uh and and
trying to monitor those
uh check the the load that we have on
the systems and and control that
um and i mean just generally like it's
really cool like that's a that's an
actual picture uh from a from a farm in
south san francisco
um so anyway that's that's some context
on um the stuff that that i've been
doing
uh in the meat space
um so is it actually different
um well these here's a couple slides
that i i took uh pictures i took this
morning
uh this is the escalator that's right
outside this
this door and it's broken that's a thing
in meat space
this is a there's a picture from my
window in the hotel
does anyone guess what's happening in
this picture
yeah they're filling in the tiles that
uh
are not on the wall anymore
so presumably they fell to the sidewalk
below
that's kind of terrifying um
but yeah uh that that's that's those are
some of the challenges that come from
from uh the meat space so systems age
and degrade and their behaviors change
over time they fall to the sidewalk um
data isn't the default so i'm
pretty positive that this hotel doesn't
have any any telemetry coming off of
their escalator
uh to know that it's it's broken um
instrumentation is really costly it's
like it's not because people are
irrational it's a rational decision
it's costly to put sensors out there all
measurement systems have error
you don't know what's in your
environment you can't you can't list it
out
you can't restart it right listening to
jenny jenny's talk
this morning a lot of the debugging
techniques that she described just
aren't possible in the physical world
there's no dev and staging environments
you can't copy and paste
consequently there's no version control
there's a huge variety in data
structures you can't make
rep rex and there's bugs
like literal bugs
[Applause]
so this is a picture from i guess i
think grace hopper
got the bug to be in the computer
science
world um because they found a moth in
their machine and i think everyone
thinks of that and they're like
oh yeah the old olden times how quaint
i personally have been responsible for
automation equipment
that stopped working properly because it
impaled a bug
um so this is like still a thing and
it's like a part of the real world
um and so one of the things that that i
think is really critical
is that the the data scientists when
they're working in the space they really
have a responsibility to go
and see and there's this concept that
comes from the toyota production system
genchi gembutsu which i'm sure is not
pronounced correctly but
um that's that's the this concept of
going to where
the work is taking place being a part of
it uh seeing it
um and so what does this all mean um
we're all familiar with this
data science workflow that comes from r
for data science
um and now that you have some context
about
you know some of the the bugs and tiles
that fall in the world
let's see like what what a workflow
might might look like
um so first the the r for data science
starts with
first you must import your data into r
um i there i just really haven't ever
come into a production space and people
are like yeah hey here's the data
you have to like go get it right in
conjunction with someone else usually
so yeah generally it doesn't doesn't
exist there and not only do you have to
get the data but you want to make
good data right it's actually going to
be be useful
so there's kind of a addition an add-on
um that gets you a pipeline to
to get started so this is kind of a call
to action that if
you're working in this space i think
you're really going to
find a great deal more success a lot
more value to whatever business that
you're working in
if you can partner with the people that
are responsible for the equipment or the
production space or
whatever it is that's happening in meat
space and work with them to make sure
that you're getting good data
in because usually that's not their
domain that's not their responsibility
they're doing it because someone told
them they had to
but if you partner with them i mean they
you know they want to do the right thing
they want to they want to add value
so it requires partnership and i'm not
going to talk about the persist
side of of this i'm just going to say
please please don't make
your own database okay
um so say that someone comes to you and
says hey ben joaquin
they're probably not going to say that
because it's a globally unique first
name
but if they come to you and say hey
let's i'm going to go
deploy this camera or something like
that
will you please work on an image
processing pipeline for me
you should stop them and say no no no
first we have to prototype um
so yeah we're going to talk about that
quickly
so prototype so however much you get
paid per per hour which uh
the previous uh presenter described um
you can look across the country um
whatever that is
times your estimate for how long this
project is going to take times
two if you're good at estimating and
you're wrong or like 20
if you're if you're not good at it plus
the opportunity cost of
this project being a total flop is
definitely more than the cost of a gopro
so you should prototype it and maybe
your gopro is not your thing and you
need a thermocouple or you need
this is a handheld ultrasound that
connects to your iphone
didn't know that was a thing i don't
know what this is at all but
whatever it is it's like definitely
definitely going to be cheaper than
going down
the uh some some path um that that isn't
isn't really possible and when you do
prototype you you get to
build some intuition for how solvable
this this problem is going to be
which is really important
this is i don't know where i first heard
this but i searched and
it turns out that some someone
referenced a phd physicist just saying
if you never miss a flight you're
spending too much time in the airport
um which i think is great um and i
totally miss flights
sometimes um so what i'm getting at here
is like yeah again having intuition
about how solvable your project is going
to be
is really important um you should make a
conscious decision that the thing that
you're
about to embark on is speculative it
might not pan out
that's the right decision for you and
your team and your business and all of
that
um and depending on what you're what
you're doing what your context is you
might err on the side of
projects that are actually going to be
solvable um
but you know i'll leave that leave that
to you
so so cool so you prototype this thing
you're going to go for it you want to
kick off
you're going to need to have some
instrumentation and you want to be
thoughtful about that so instrumenting
um
you know probably isn't isn't driven by
you
uh generally i think maybe exclusively
you're gonna have somebody that you're
gonna partner with that's responsible
for physical components
um definitely go with some industrial
instrumentation it can be really
expensive but it's totally worth the
cost
um raspberry pies are cool
but they don't work that well when
they're filled with water
so um yeah don't don't do that
um integration costs often dominate
projects so um
if you're going to have to deploy new
new uh types of sensors or
instrumentation
in the future try to think about that
some you know pick
a platform that is going to be scalable
appropriately with with the work that
you can anticipate
and always remember that measurement
systems have to capture the signal
that you're going to use i've totally
seen this happen
many times someone goes gets a sensor
they plug it in
hey now let's measure whatever it is and
we're going to control on it but the
resolution of that sensor just doesn't
include what
the signal that you actually need and
hopefully we'll figure that out from
from prototyping so just because you
found
gold in dirt doesn't mean you can turn
dirt into
gold my friend and colleague bishop says
this
we uh yeah sounds like he's around um
uh you're not an alchemist um you're not
a magician
so um yeah so keep that in mind and make
sure you communicate that to other
people because lots of people think that
you are
a magician or an alchemist
so here's a really cool example of of us
doing this
really successfully so imagine that you
want to take a measurement from the
bottom of the plant
to the first leaf on the on the chute
uh and that that process i mean
typically again the default is that
there's there's not instrumentation out
there
so someone is physically holding that
plant and physically taking a
measurement device to it
uh and then they maybe like type it down
or something like that
so something that we've done that's been
really successful is okay cool somebody
wants to move that
into a digital space so we're going to
take a picture of the plant
and then we get the person to take that
measurement
from the picture and what that does is
it means you have to align
the resolution necessary for that person
to then do the task
has to be in the picture in order for
them to execute on that successfully
and so that that can be a good paradigm
to do that and i think there's similar
parallels
in in other applications as well
so calibration calibration is also
really critical
so let's talk about that quickly there's
tons and tons of great
content in the world about this but you
want to quantify
your measurement system error every
every measurement system has error
you have no clue like if you wanted to
characterize the room temperatures
uh the temperatures in this room
whatever device you're going to use is
going to have error you need to
understand what that is and what the
caveats are
i would consider using a derived metric
so
yeah again let's take the temperature in
this room it has some set point right
there's a thermostat here somewhere
that's trying to achieve a specific
temperature
if you wanted to have an alert be thrown
on
the hvac system performing out of out of
spec
don't set that limit on the actual
temperature set it as a margin
on the setpoint so again there's lots
and lots of great content in the world
about that
and then consider having a standard data
model for
for your data if you're if you work with
a lot of temperature data uh you might
want to have
your own standard uh system or your
structure for
for that data so that different uh
instrumentation approaches you take
different suppliers
you can merge all of that stuff and plug
it into a constant
approach which you then can work on sort
of agnostic of how you got that data
to begin with and if you do all these
things
i think there's an opportunity to create
a virtuous cycle
right where you're then collecting good
data in the meat space
you're able to put it into a database
that you didn't create
and then you import that stuff you go
through your data science workflow you
build understanding
and then that has the ability to feed
back into additional
uh instrumentation and and changes that
that might be
made out in the in the real world
um and yeah i want to thank uh
my team i've worked with a bunch of
really tremendous people
uh will derek dana who just gave a talk
on scales
so you missed it but you should
definitely watch it
chris sasha nico nate and my wife corey
thanks
[Applause]
thanks ben joaquin we have a few
questions queued up for you
um can you give an example of some of
your work
going through the whole meet space plus
data science workflow
at your company um
[Music]
yeah sure yeah so so a good example
would be
um there's we have a piece of automation
equipment the current current company
where uh it's actually super cool what
it does is it has a
drum so imagine a cylinder that has a
bunch of holes on it
and those holes we draw a vacuum on on
the chamber that those holes are
attached to and then we rotate the drum
over
a bed of seeds and the vacuum then
sucks up seeds onto it and as it rotates
it then drops the vacuum and the seeds
fall onto a tray
and so someone wanted to to
have us come up with a vision system
that would allow us to detect the
success
of sucking those seeds up onto the drum
and we said yeah sure that sounds like a
cool idea but
please go take a gopro and stick it out
there
and tell me if you can actually do that
yourself
and what we've got into there was that
they hadn't thought about the fact that
they actually
cared a lot about the quantity of seeds
that it sucked up
um and what we were actually able to do
what the human was able to do with with
that video
was just to see if there was a presence
or absence but if you had two seeds or
three seeds it was actually incredibly
difficult
to tell the difference and so we learned
a lot there and we're able to
restructure the project based on that
understanding
that's really cool thank you oftentimes
our coders aren't brought into the
conversation
early enough i.e after instrumentation
is decided etc
any advice on how to approach that
situation
yeah i think my my advice there would be
um
to to try to build those relationships i
i definitely have lived
that time and time again that
i think it's often a secondary thought
that you're going to then have some
machine learning ai driven
manufacturing facility um and so
um it's not it's not a part of the
conversation like like this person's
pointing out in the design
phases um but i think that the best
practice there is like
to to keep working with those people you
know they're they're trying to do
the best that they can they probably
don't have a good understanding of
what's possible that's a big thing that
we do is we we try to bring
a solution space that that the rest of
the organization just isn't aware of
isn't thinking about
and bring that into into the meat space
into the world that they're trying to
design and build
um and yeah i think you can iterate
through that and make it clear that
if we want to have the types of whiz
bang things that that people want
uh it needs to be designed in and
thought about at the beginning phase
thank you eduardo if you don't mind uh
coming up we'll take one more question
while you set up
how do you switch to a career in meet
space if your background is all
in tech slash virtual spaces uh well
you can talk to me because we're hiring
especially if you're interested in
computer vision
um i think that the reality is is that
there's
we were talking today there was a bird
of feathers
for manufacturing folks and
they're just there's not a great
community out there
so maybe we need to to build build that
up
there's a number of companies that do
things like manufacturing that's where i
have the most
experience i think that bird could help
me help you if you tell it or i'm not
sure how it works but but try that
and maybe maybe
fantastic thank you ben joaquin